你不是眼睛喜欢绿色，而是说大脑补充了一种深处在北欧清冷又有点温润的那种森林当中的联想，它是关于温度和湿度的。
人的审美敏感期大概是在5到15岁，也就是说我们其实是对自己小时候接触过的style会产生强烈功名，其实这个就是我们中国人经常说的童年律境嘛。
复古不是你再度拥有一个单品，而是说你能通过它回到一个美好年代，复古它是不是提供了一种对当下的救赎。
大家好，欢迎收听余光Post，我是惠斯。
我是Jackie。
今天我们聊的品牌是一家Ikea，我觉得这是一个让大家都特别有亲切感的品牌，就无论租房还是有了自己的小家，那逛一家其实都是周六、周日可以安排一整天的活动。
那为什么我们在2025年的今天要聊一家呢？其实有两个原因，第一个就是一家今年在全球范围内重磅发布了斯德格尔摩2025系列。
那这个系列其实是一家最有设计感，或者用Jackie的评划说说是他最有野心的一个系列。
对对对，那在中国地区呢，一家这个系列的发布选在了上海的一间老洋房。
这家老洋房其实是夏严老先生的舅居，整套家具搭配老洋房，可以说氛围感拉满。
所以这个系列的设计非常值得聊一聊。
那另外呢就是我和Jackie前后脚都装修了，他甚至还在欧洲买了斯德格尔摩2025系列的单品。
所以我们就趁着热乎气儿聊聊一家的这个系列，2025年的这个斯德格尔摩。
那我们这期其实不是新系列的测评，而是从设计的角度，就是来拆解一下。
因为今儿这也是算Jackie的专业了，它是平时做艺术和设计的。
就是到底是什么样的底层规律，能让一个系列，比如说这个斯德格尔摩，让人整体上觉得很舒服。
那设计这个魔术到底耍了什么花招？
我们一般人是不是也可以借点一些设计上的搭配规律让我们的家更好看，更舒服呢？
然后还有我们想聊另外一个话题，就是一家是如何酝酿一个新系列的。
就是是设计师派脑门发起的吗？那答案肯定不是，
因为它作为商业化这么成功的一个跨国公司，一定有它的机制，既保证设计又平衡市场。
所以今天我们就来扒一扒，一家内部是怎么决策推出一个新系列的。
那当然其实我们还有一个衍生化题，也就是为什么斯德格尔摩我们称它其实是个边粘题，
就是它有2025年这样的一个角逐，就是一家是如何复活一款老设计，就是又如何预测复古趋势的呢？
今天这个就是我们主要想聊的话题，我们话不多说，正片开始。
就首先我们来品一品一家斯德格尔摩2025的设计。
其实我们结了几张光的图，大家要是能看屏幕的话，就可以看一眼图。
要是不能也没关系，就是可以先听一下我们的拆解。
好，然后Jackie，Jackie的专业，她现在带领大家一遍一遍设计。
对，因为其实斯德格尔摩这个系列，他刚出的时候，就是今年2025初的时候，我就注意到他了。
他本身好像在设计师的圈子里口碑是蛮好的。
然后我注意到2025这个系列，其实是因为他今年这个系列把材质跟感官的一些东西用的特别的好。
就是他会给我感觉他既低调，但是又舒适，又高级，但是又不至于说跟我们家的一些东西去相斥。
然后我就会觉得说，哎，那正好赶上装修啊什么的，这是一个挺好的选择，就去看一看他的食物。
然后来看食物的时候，我个人感觉手感是还可以的，就是相对其他的一家的那个产品来说。
所以我想先跟大家说一个概念，就是感官设计这个概念。
就是他简单来说呢，他是只除了我们可以使用视觉上的好看，去作为设计的主要参考，或者说引导。
但同时我们其实也是可以把触觉啊，秀觉啊，味觉啊等等这些东西都去考虑进来，去纳入设计的范围里。
因为一般来讲，我们提到设计，可能我们先想到的就是，无论是一张海报，还是一个桌子，设计应该是在管他好不好看这件事，对不对。
对，有没有隔掉，有没有高级感。
对，然后他如果承载了一些信息啊，什么的，就是你的信息传达是不是比较清晰，然后比较就是符合人的直觉的感觉。
OK，但这个其实都是眼睛的范畴，对吧。
但是感官设计这个概念，他就是只设计的过程中，应该去系统性的考虑人的多种感官，然后去创造更丰富，更沉浸，然后引导性也会更强的一种体验。
所以他不仅仅是看得见的部分，为什么会就是要引入感官设计呢？
是因为在很多的产品或者说情境之下，感官的优先级他是不一样的。
我在这里给大家举一个例子，就是比如说在商业空间当中嗅觉和音乐他的情绪引导作用和这个消费决策，
占的比例就会特别特别的高，比如说星巴克，星巴克从最初创牌的时候到今天他一直在运用的就是他自己的咖啡的香味，
然后去把人引到他的空间里去进行购买等等的，然后产生这个咖啡星巴克品牌星巴克空间的这样一个联系，
然后还有其他的比如说茅荣玩具，茅荣玩具呢他就是另外一种，他在设计的时候其实就要去考虑触觉会考虑的非常多，尤其是儿童使用的那种小玩偶像Jellycat之类的，
因为触觉他会触发人对这个身体安全或者是亲密感，然后使用依恋啊什么就是是跟这些东西密切相关的。
所以就是回到我们这个2025的斯德哥尔摩系列或者说家居设计当中，就是触感他反而是要优先于视觉的，
也就是说人们坐下躺下然后握持的时候的这些体验其实是比外观更有决定性的。
就是Jellycat说到之后就想不到装修时，当时我装修时很纠结的一个问题，就是家里到底要不要铺地毯，
就是他们就是所有的装修美图，如果他把地毯这个扣图给扣走的话就都差了点意思，
他可以说是客厅氛围的稳定器，但是要说真铺地毯的话，他清洁起来实在太麻烦了，
之前我刷讲说还有看到说一个整装公司的老板下洁论说没有人买地毯是为了使用，
是不是还挺亲屁的，大实话，但我还是买了地毯，原因很简单，就是刚刚Jellycat说的就是被低估的触觉，
就是像地毯的这个软，它会延伸到我的整个的视觉评估体系，哪怕我的脚没踩到它，
但是我能把这种柔软舒适的感觉和想象以偏开拳的作用到整个家，
对我来说家就是我们能够温柔欠入的这个空间，就是地毯它等于温柔，它等于一个好的触觉。
感官其实对人的认知是有很强的引导性的，
但是在工业设计这个领域，它就有非常非常多的研究去看不同的材质对用户的心理啊，
或者行为上的一些影响，比如说我们提到木头，它就会自然的给人带来温暖感，自然感。
但是如果是金属的话，它就会带来一种理性、冷静、专业感，就是这种想象。
或者说丝绒这个材质，一般来说丝绒经常会去连接的就是亲密柔和，而且是偏丝密空间的那种点想。
你这么一说确实，那个书桌有的时候配的那个椅子，
如果是我之前看的包豪丝设计，它可能是一种钢管的椅子的结构，
然后就会给人感觉这种很冷静、很立质的感觉。
有感觉是一个男人在用它。
这有点性别路了。
你也在用是不是？
对，我也在用。
没有，我要开玩笑。
但是你说的这个确实它是包豪丝设计它比较崇尚的那个点嘛。
正好就是借着这个绘丝的这个，我们可以先说一下就是这个设计的概念，
比如说刚才提到的包豪丝。
其实包豪丝它是一种现在注意设计，
然后它成型的时间是大概1919到1960年左右嘛，
就是因为它本身强调功能性，还有形式它要追随它的功能性，
然后结构要集结，理性这些点，
然后所以才会给像惠斯刚才留下那种，
它感觉像一个男人，
甚至是一个businessman的那种去使用它的一个感觉，
然后为什么要提到这个现代主义设计呢？
是因为其实一家所用的这种北欧设计，
它跟现代主义设计它相当于一个地域性转移的版本，
就本身的北欧设计成型的时间要比包豪丝稍微晚一点点，
然后它的盛期大概是六七十年代左右，
它相当于继承了现代主义的股价，
比如说包括它的几何形的结构啊，
然后要去装饰啊，
还有要比较容易进行工业量产，这些标准，
然后当然在这个基础上呢，
北欧人又把设计这件事又填了一些人文主义的血肉在里面，
就是它比较强调人与自然共处，生活节奏平缓，
而且要可感知他们会遵循这种设计哲学，
所以说可以说北欧设计是把人从工厂的办公室，
然后又一定程度的拉回了自然和森林，
它就会更有人味，
北欧设计它是从二世纪中期开始就非常强调人与自然的关系，
然后它会非常重视日常生活中的亲密性啊，
以及它本身就对天然材料有很强的偏好，
所以北欧设计它是在实践当中天然的感官化了，
这就是为什么它非常符合感官设计这个东西，
我觉得也和它的北欧那个环境有关系，
就是我们即使去旅游去那边的话，
也会觉得它整个哪怕是城市，
但它也充满了自然感，
那边的人他可能就很爱骑自行车，
他不爱开车，
然后那边的人可能就会天然的喜欢徒步，
我觉得他们的生活本身就是有一定的自然属性的，
这个也离不开他们整体的图上。
刚才我们就是大家讲了一下感官设计这个概念，
然后下面我们就可以评一下斯特格尔摩2025，
他们的这种风格，
我们可以做一个设计风格的拆解，
那我们听有空的话，
可以看一下我们找的这个官网图都在PPT里面了，
我看到这个图的感觉就是它元素丰富，
就它其实和我一开始想象的北欧设计，
还是有一点不同的。
其实我们可以在这里面就对着图去看一看，
它都用了哪些材质，
其实真的就是惠斯说的就是材质丰富，
它可能会有比如沙发，
它是丝绒的，
然后椅子腾条，
然后灯它用的是那种玻璃管，
然后你可以看就是它会有什么还有金属，
绿质什么的，
就是各种各样的小小的元素，
而且感觉它们的每个的材质都会很不一样。
但是它的这种材质其实不是随机拼接的，
它是非常有节奏的去组织起来的，
因为2025这个系列里，
它其实有一条明线，
就是它本身是的确是要多使用雅光，
比较温润的木纹，
然后不锋利的边角，
它为了是比如说你的触感上的，
触觉的安全感，
然后视觉的舒适，
但是为什么说它是明显的，
因为它还有一个暗线，
就是你看它在搭配的时候，
它是要你看到丝绒，
然后你要看到木头，
又看到木头，
但是你要跳出来，
又看到一个腾条，
又看到玻璃，
然后要回到木头金属绿质，
然后又回到木头，
它其实是一种节奏感，
你明白我这个感觉吗？
因为它这个样子，
它能让我们的感官。
会有很多的对应关系，
比如说后时的，
它会突然间又对应了一个清盈的东西，
然后冷感的会对应有温度的东西，
所以它就建立了一种。
日常情感的节奏和秩序，
然后这个就是我刚才说的，
在材质方面的它那条暗线，
那我们停一下，
我代表观众提问，
因为我觉得Jackie她自己会有很多，
就是也还挺金句的比喻，
什么是节奏感，
就是我如何理解，
你说了一堆就是家具上面的材质，
但是你告诉我它有节奏感，
仿佛音乐一般，
对，其实你这个说法是很准确的，
它就是仿佛你听音乐一样，
还有高音，它有低音，
它会有些叮叮咚咚的装饰音等等的，
这个就是材质混搭所提供出来的一种，
你视觉上的一种节奏感，
就是像我刚才说的，
什么木头啊，金属啊，
又跳回到木头啊等等的，
它一方面提供了一种对比，
但是它也提供了一种气口，
就你不能总是在一种材质里面，
去现代里面的，
就是脆弱的和坚固的交织，
柔软的和坚硬的也要交织，
就大家可以想象一下，
比如说我们喜欢柔软这件事，
但是如果一个房间，
它全部用的是柔软的丝绒，
那它看起来就不会像家了，
它会特别像窗帘城，
是是是，
所以真正让人觉得这是我可以住的空间，
它恰巧就是因为，
棉马去对金属，
木头衬托玻璃，
藤边穿插皮革，
这种多材质的搭配，
它会带来一种心理起伏，
也就是空间的气口嘛，
然后斯德格尔摩系列，
我觉得就是，
挺非常非常懂这个节奏的，
心理的起伏，
但是能再解释一下嘛，
你可以把它理解为，
一种,
寻宝的快乐吧，
比如说我们再回到刚才那张图的话，
比如我们看一个，
无论是一个展厅图，
还是说你到了一家的样板间也，
你到了你家也吧，
就是慧斯你看那张图，
你先看到的是什么？
我先看到这个大面积的色块，
其实是地毯，
然后你的眼睛会去追到哪里？
你能看到它上面的餐桌椅？
对，就是你看这个图，
你是一点一点推进，
一点点看完的，
它就是一种类似于寻宝的快乐嘛，
然后这些其实都是，
设计师埋伏在里面的点，
所以是心理埋伏是吧？
不是心理起伏，
心理吧，也可以，
心理埋伏对对对，
单品上，
其实斯德格尔摩系列，
也在用一个相同的方法，
比如说它有一款台灯，
这个台灯它的底座，
是用一种类似于石料，
一样的一个材质，
然后就会特别准固的能。
对，能够呆在这个桌面上，
但是它的支撑部分，
又用了相对来讲，
比较纤细感的金属，
但是这个金属就会给人感觉，
兼顾，但是它又精致，
然后当你在网上看的时候，
它的灯罩又用了支物，
然后它就会让你觉得，
柔软舒适，
你放在你的床头是没有什么问题的，
然后说到这个单品，
我就会想起我爸妈，
比如说我买这款台灯，
他们的第一评价就是，
这个东西看着挺厚实的，
好东西，这钱啊，
对对对，厚实，
就对他们来说很重要，
但是这个厚实，
或者说他们觉得这种可靠的感觉，
其实并不是说那个灯罩，
那个支物部分提供的，
比做提供的成分是比较大的，
对，然后我们如果再回归到，
这个产品的宣传图，
就是这方面呢，
我们就，你就更容易能够发现，
这种材质混搭的
魅力和学问了，
比如说阳光下的这个餐桌，
它是圆角的，
然后它的木头桌衣，
但是它又加了玻璃的器皿，
然后支物感的钓灯，
就是大家可以想象一下，
就是比如说，
这个支物感的钓灯给去掉，
换成同系列的，
有一款那个玻璃管的那个钓灯，
你就会觉得这张图，
其实没有那么那么的舒服，
因为它会显得整个氛围特别脆，
然后也不够温馨，
所以不同的材质，
它要扮演不同的角色，
然后要相互交织配合，
才能够产生和谐的效果，
这个就是我觉得，
混搭的魅力了，
那这样啊，
就是我问Jackie哥问题，
因为就我88自己在装修，
他们特别喜欢浅色，
所以他们买了很多，
就是以加的白色家具，
然后现在，
其实有一种家种风格，
在小户买很流行，
比如说法式奶油风，
奶白色很多，
那Jackie就是会有什么，
搭配材质上的建议吗？
材质上，
我觉得就可以遵循，
就是遵循我刚才说的这种，
看能不能尝试去找节奏感，
但是其实更简单的一个方法，
就是去玩这个配色，
因为有一个最简单的配色方法，
它叫做6比3比1嘛，
就假设你的最大面积的颜色是白色，
你还要去找一个
大概占3成的使用量的颜色，
去让你这个家，
增加一点，
不一样的感觉，
然后最后你再用点特殊的颜色，
去把性格给拎出来，
所以它叫做6比3比1，
它的这个比例，
其实比你具体使用什么颜色要更重要，
对我来说，
好的,
我来这个，
我再帮我爸妈这个装修把把关，
用你这个6比3比1的这个，
这个公式去套一下，
好呀，就是，
刚才我们就讲完了，
这个话题呢，
现在就我们来再评一评一家这个系列的配色，
首先就是，
我看到这个配色的感觉，
就是觉得，
它其实自然色主导吧，
因为它会用一些
原木家具，绿质，
还有一些灰色的背景，
我感觉其实是，
大部分人都会觉得舒适的色调，
但是，它语中不同意一点，
就是我对这个系列，
感觉有记忆点的点是，
就是说，它有一个正绿色的边骨，
我感觉是特别特别正的那种绿，
就有点像小孩会喜欢的那种绿，
然后,
它的沙发，
是江黄色的，
也是蛮有个性的一种颜色，
就会让我想到香料，
然后还有就孔雀蓝，
也是一种蛮特殊的颜色，
所以就是，
这个是我对这个系列，
色彩的一个感受啊，
确实,
它会用到一些跳色嘛，
但是这种跳色，
我是认为，它仍然需要遵循。
整个这个斯德格尔摩2025系列的，
所谓的这个自然感的，
它是不能跟这个相互背斥的，
就是你看到这些颜色的时候，
它可以不是
真实的，比如说，
树的颜色，或者胡博的颜色，
但是，它仍然需要。
引发你对自然的联想，
就是你不是说眼睛喜欢绿色，
而是说大脑补充了一种。
身处在北欧，清冷，
又有点温润的那种森林当中的联想，
它是关于温度和湿度的，
然后这几个颜色，
其实我觉得是遵循的，
这种设计逻辑，
它并不是一个脱轨的特殊情况。
关于自然色的这个联想，
是，比如说，
这里面选用的这种，
很出跳的绿色，
和那个蓝绿色，
它本身是自然色的，
一个现代的演艺，
它是森林啊，湖泊啊的象征，
而不是这些东西的本色，
像我刚才说的那样。
然后另外还有一个点，
就是斯德格尔摩，
这个系列选的色彩的圆形，
它是符合天然染料，
或者是矿物染料的圆圆。
你这么一说就对了，
就是江黄色，
刚才我刚想到的是香料，
然后，就是你这么一说，
就是那个孔雀蓝，
它好像也是有这种，
就像千里江山图那种蓝，
就是也是那种古代，
就会研磨出来那种颜料。
对对对，
就我们这么说可能，
大家会不是特别能够理解，
为什么这种颜色，
它是自然的，
我举一个反例吧，
就是在这个斯德格尔摩系列，
2025推出的时候，
其实同时期还有一个春天的系列，
然后那个春天的系列，
它是用了明黄，
然后亮粉，
也用了绿色为配色，
但是你看斯德格尔摩系列，
它为什么不能去用那个，
亮粉色和明黄呢？
就是它本身其实也很挑，
很有个性，也很好看，
但是问题是，
你在诉说，
安静自然低调，
时间感的时候，
但是明黄跟亮粉，
它这种现代化学
染料体系的颜色，
它说的是playful，
然后化学，
注意力，及时行恶，
然后这个就会跟它的材质什么的，
或者跟它的整体的，
灰色说的背景版，
就有点击通压奖了，
对，确实那个，
亮粉就会让你想，
就是泥红灯，
就是它那种银光色，
就是一种现代工业化的产物，
对，对，对，
它是一种相对来讲比较新的颜色，
它不是古老的那种。
所以，总体来说，
斯德格尔摩系列，
它必须要遵循的一个底色，
就是海照自然，
其实这个和它北欧设计的，
这个圆头性其实是相关的，
反而设计部分，
我们聊完了之后，
其实我自己也有好奇的点，
就是,
一家它内部是怎么去。
协同和推出这样的一个。
新的系列的，
就是这个商业部分的，
其实不知道汇斯有没有了解，
这个，其实这个特别有意思的问题，
就是一个系列，
它是如何诞生的，
就是套用赵本山的话说，
这笼工分三步，
我们来一一看看它一共有几步，
第一步很重要的一步，
就是说，咱拿斯德格尔摩，
这整个系列来取例子吧，
首先它第一步就是要有一个出发点，
也就是说，
设计团队，还有市场团队，
他们可能共同决查到了一种。
举个例子，比如说，
设计团队它就会发现，
某个独立设计师的品牌，
那我们随便说，这不代表是真实的品牌，
比如说，单卖有一个品牌，
它叫End Tradition,。
但这几年它那个，就磨锅灯也很火嘛，
所以它就发现市场上，
这种小众作品，
是比较受到中产阶层的追捧的，
但是它价格很高，
这是设计团队，
那市场团队呢，它也有一个发现，
就发现就是中等价位的。
设计款家居，
它存在市场缺口，
就具体说来，其实就是消费者，
其实不愿意为基础款妥协，
觉得挺没意思的，
但又买不起真正的设计师原作，
那这就是一家的拿手好戏，
就是能够让普通人享受好设计，
所以这两边一对呢，
他们可能就会得出一个结论，
就是我们可以推出一个。
北欧风的一家内部的一个高端线，
然后比较像
北欧设计，
这是经典设计之径，
这是第一步，
那第二步呢，出发点有了，
那它其实就要进入下一个阶段，
就是趋势捕捉阶段，
那其实后面的每个阶段，
市场团队还有设计团队，
他们都是要分头出发，
拿到答案，
然后大部分的时候，
他们还要互相challenge，互相battle，
就是过程非常有趣，
我们展开说说，
比如说这个趋势捕捉阶段，
比如说他们会去看这个。
米兰家具展，
他们有什么风向，
比如说最近流行这个。
牧制的这个桌椅腿，
然后上面有一个金属，
比如说类似这样的一个趋势，
然后他们还会就是去查看一下，
就是攀通社近年的趋势，
输出一个设计和预测类的文档，
但是这个，
其实攀通社这个一家会用多少，
之前我Jackie有一个讨论，
就是因为，
其实就是一家内部是有专门的团队。
来研究色彩这一块，
他们和攀通社更多的是一种合作的关系，
有的时候也会去参考，
那他们这个团队的研究范围很有意思，
我当时看到觉得这个忍不住。
想要跟大家分享一下，
比如说他们研究红色，
那中国红和北欧红，
他们的差别在哪里，
就是他们应该应用到。
什么样的家具，
面向什么样的市场，
比如说都是红色，
就是让人远处就一下子。
能够看到那种红，
那北欧红呢，
它是那种像雪地里，
被西洋染过的木屋，
这种感觉的红，
大家可以想象一下，
灰度高，然后有这种做就感，
这更像是一种，
绣红,
所以红和红还不一样，
所以其实一家会围绕这些东西，
这个设计团队会有非常多的输出，
然后这个是设计团队，
输出这种设计预测类等等，
然后在趋势捕捉阶段，
市场队他们其实也会做大量的工作，
这个其实是和我之前做战略资源差不多的，
两步走，
一个是要做用户研究，
还有一个是做进品调查，
我一看就觉得非常的眼熟，
那比如说做用联，
他们的关键结论可能就会类似于。
现在都市的年轻人，
愿意为石木多付15%的一家，
但是拒绝超过30%的一家，
其实已经非常高的量化水平了，
他们的结论，
那比如说他们还会走查进品，
那他可能会得到一个关键结论，
就是我们也随便举例，
比如说Zara Home,。
我们假设是他进队，
然后他最近的这个北欧仿之品增长迅猛，
我们就说比如说有30%的增长，
所以他侧面反映了大众的一个虚处，
所以这两边一对，
可能就是这个系列，
他就会强调原木，
然后北欧仿之品，
这就是某类颜色的应用，
所以这个是第二阶段，
然后趋势捕捉阶段，
然后还他们还有第三个阶段，
第三个阶段叫创意原型阶段，
那这个时候呢，
其实设计团队是可以自由创作的，
比如说Zara Goma系列的设计师，
他需要想象Zara Goma市中心。
一间50平米的公寓里面的完美家具，
长什么样，
那他的初期体验，
可能会包含一些非常激进的设计，
比如说部队称的柜题，
但是这里面，
其实他们还要，
除了市场团队，
还有设计团队，
还有一个很重要的团队，
他其实是工程团队，
他们要去审核，
看这样的一个设计能不能量产，
那设计团队忙活完了，
这个时候设计的市场团队就要入场了，
去检验设计师们的美好想象，
能不能稍微成功，
那他们具体的方法呢，
其实是进行压力测试，
就是啥是压力测试，
就比如说市场团队，
它会拿着这个格尔摩，
它的设计原型，
比如说一款沙发，
和一个和一组竞品来混摆，
他们等在市中心组长的一个地方，
然后来观察消费者们，
他们是不是愿意多走两步，
去摸一摸这个创业原型，
其实这个就象征了，
就是大家会不喜欢它，
发自内心的喜欢，
然后一个更重要的压力测试，
是设计能不能通过规模化的量产，
把价格打下来，
比如说在市场团队里面，
他们还会有一个成本和算团队，
他们其实是要去解一道数学题，
就比如说，
如果我们这个斯勒尔摩的沙发，
它的销量能够达到比如说10万件，
那是不是就能将真笔沙发的价格，
压到1799欧，
就他们其实是要做这样的数学题的，
就是这样的压力测试，
在这个过程中，
就是这个市集团队，
还有市场团队，
会有非常多轮的针尖队迈茫，
他们可以理解为这种对抗性的合作。
其实我说到这儿，
有一个问题想问Jack，
就是你平时是做设计的，
就是谈到设计和市场的博弈，
你有没有类似的感受，
就是之间要互相battle？
有啊，经常啊，
我们要跟各方battle，
你要跟你的甲方团队里，
它可能会有项目经理，
然后他们有自己的目的，
为什么要做这一套设计，
然后我要去跟他去battle，
然后同时我可能还会要去跟供应商battle，
比如说你要设计，
等到落地实现的时候，
他需要工厂去给你进行制作什么的，
然后要考虑他的成本之类，
你要跟他battle，
然后有的时候这三方会互相battle，
然后就是如果还有其他的角色在里面的话，
那就是真的是一个混战的状态，
但其实这是一个开玩笑的说法，
实际上就是，
这个关系还是相对来讲比较和谐的，
设计对于我来说，
本身它就是一个带着角料跳舞的这样一个状态，
设计没有人会让你自己百分之百的去发挥，
然后发挥出一个根本对这个世界。
没有任何帮助和意义的东西的，
那个太不现实了，
所以解决问题，
然后这个本身就是设计当中，
必须要去思考和，
就是你必须要一直带着这个想法的，
所以我觉得像一家的这种battle，
我觉得他们甚至可能，
就比我能接触到的要更成熟，
就是他们的合作应该会相当丝滑的，
我是觉得这个东西还挺有激情的，
实际上就是一些头脑风暴，
然后灵感的碰撞嘛，
然后每一个部门它带着自己发现的问题，
和它能够为别人提出的解决方案，
然后大家一起去碰，
那个潮是，
我觉得是不伤情感的，
除非就是不健康的那种，
就是潮家，
或者说有一些利益就个什么的在里面，
这个不算，
但正常的设计流程上，
如果出现了这种，
你说的不对，我反驳你，
你说的不对，我去反驳你，
就是这样的过程，
其实挺有激情，挺快乐的，
这个设计师，
这个站出来说了，
我们是很快乐，
很愿意跟你们battle的，
自我洗脑，
可能演示，
好好好，
我们再聊第三个话题，
这个话题其实是这个眼神话题，
就是说，
就是为什么，
这个色格尔摩系列，
它是这个，
被标注了2025，
它为什么这个编年题，
以及这个一家的是光机理论，
就是说，
先说这个色格尔摩系列，
它其实首次是在1984年文石，
所以到我们今天中年讲的这个2025，
中年它其实是被复活了很多次，
因为色格尔摩，
它这个系列，
它并不是一个单一主张的，
就是如果你去看的话，
它并不是一直都是现在的颜色，
和现在的风格等等的，
它是根据它不同的年代，
是会产生很大的变化的，
因为它扮演的角色，
是一个一家内部的风格实验室，
如果我们去看它前几代的话，
你会发现，
有几代它的那个自然性，
而是退居到比较靠后的一个位置了，
它会反而去重视都市感，
或者说我要追寻装饰性，
所以说只是在2025这个世代，
它迎来了一个自然性的高峰，
它并不是代表说斯多格尔摩一直以来都是这个主张，
就是其实在设计，
然后包括艺术，
就是它，
就这些门类啊，
它都不是抽象的一些学科门类，
就是可能跟大家认为的设计师，
艺术家都是很自由的啊，
什么的不一样，
反而是要有很强的理论之称，
它有大量的理论研究，
然后也有技术的迭代，
没有哪一个创作，
真的是一拍脑的灵感来了，
就能直接做出来了，
然后尤其是对一家这种品牌来说，
它建立自己的资料库整合语言，
然后避免设计风格施交，
就显得就是格外的重要了，
这个就是说到这个编年题的一个意义。
刚才Jackie说的，
就是现实层面上，
就是他会把自己的设计归党，
就是除了，
就是我们想象的一种信息归党，
这个归党这个词，就是archive嘛，
但其实在线下，
它形成了一个设计档案馆，
它真的有一个IKEA music，
就是一家博物馆，
然后就在位置啊，
地理位置就在瑞典那个小城，
这个词我不太会念啊，
就A开头的一个词，
也是一家的发源地，
然后总部在那边。
所以就是设计框，
如果去瑞典玩的时候，
一定不要错过，
可以把它当成一个特色景点去逛一逛。
那一家它是怎么决策某种设计，
要不要在眼下复活呢？
这个其实是牵扯到一家对于复古的预测，
你说复古咋预测呢？
它到底是回到未来还是回到过去呢？
就是像Jackie说的，
就没有一拍脑门的设计，
就是对于一家这种产品覆盖全球的公司更惨势，
他们其实是通过数据考古，
代计行为分析，
甚至是文化事件的监测，
这一系列的补充，
去精准补卓，
哪些就设计值得复活。
那下面我们就来看一下。
一家的方法论，
首先啊，
就是它有一个30年循环论，
这个就是一家的复古依据嘛，
然后它其实牵扯到了一个底层规律，
就是人的审美敏感期，
大概是在5到15岁，
也就是说，
我们其实是对自己小时候接触过的style，
会产生强烈功名，
就是这个例子，
比如说千席一代，
千席一代大概就是80后95前，
我们就算千席一代，
就是会在2010年前后，
就是这个地位，
它喜欢波西米亚风，
那根源就在于他们的童年，
正好赶上了就是
父辈的CP式文化，
渗入主流，
当然这个是欧美文化圈的现象，
就是但就是一家其实，
它也是这个文化圈的产物嘛，
就是这个新环，
就那么一说，
我确实回起来，
大概是2010年，
就是那个时候，
如果鸟去淘宝商买一些地塔，
甚至是靠电，
都是那种，
就是波西米亚风的，
它可能是大的风格，
可能从这儿来了，
那之前，
就是一家的设计总监就说过，
就是我们不会忙目复刻，
而是选择的那些在社交媒体上，
已经被新一代，
自拉讨论的旧款来复刻，
这通常发生在原版推出之后的，
18到32年,
你看看多精准，
就那么具体，
当然其实一家不太敢，
在中国市场用这个策略，
因为中国的预约生活发展太快了，
可以说，
欧美的30年循环，
到了中国这儿，
可能要压缩，
可能是20年的循环，
其实这个就是我们，
中国人经常说的，
童年旅境嘛，
最近我也经常看到，
就是,
地铁上又看到，
有人穿飞跃的那个白球鞋，
还有就是，
香水,
又出了大白兔奶糖味的香水，
其实都是在照顾我们的回忆嘛，
就是这个，
一家它是通过类似这样的机制，
去预测的，
然后此外呢，
其实就，
我们就比较好想象了，
就是这种二手市场的行为数据，
比如说，
一家会关注这种，
欧洲拍卖行的成交指数，
或者意思上的这种标签挖掘，
对于他们来讲，
这都是一家的复刻信号，
或者是壁垒信号，
然后就哪些不要去复刻，
最后一个就是技术层面上，
就是说，
当我们复刻的时候，
它这个材料是不是普及了？
是的,
因为一个风格，
它从出生到复古，
中间的那个沉浸期，
其实就是在等待技术跟产业的进步，
就是某一个复古的到来，
它是暗示着上一轮，
没能实现的一些东西，
然后时隔了几十年，
它迎来了技术上的突破，
现在可以再去远当年的那个梦的感觉了。
比如说像斯德格尔摩2025系列，
我们就可以去看，
它其实暗示的是什么，
它暗示的是一家的内部，
应该是在可持续原料物流供应链这方面，
已经完成了准备期，
所以正好，
就是借着这个时候去推2025系列，
然后制定自然感这个标签，
然后借此来谋定自己，
设计普及者的这个地位。
也非常多现实层面上，
就是普及、城门这方面的考量。
那好，那我们再说回来，
就是斯德格尔摩系列，
它到底在一家中扮演了什么角色呢？
对斯德格尔摩系列，
反正因为做这一期，
我就分别去看了，
它80年代、90年代，
还有2016年的扫描图册，
然后发现很多单品，
但是如今是不在斯德格尔摩系列中的，
它反而给放到了其他的系列里，
就是曾经比如说在斯德格尔摩系列当中，
出现过的单品的设计言，
或结构样式，
甚至是配色的策略，
后来会被转移到
一家的其他的常规系列当中，
就是它相当于是
一家的一个先锋测试区，
它虽然从一开始就被定义为。
高质量，
然后实验性有这种。
形象品牌线的那种感觉，
所以它会用这个系列去。
试验材料比例，
模块,
包括色彩策略等等的，
但并不是说所有的。
成功的斯德格尔摩设计，
最后都还会留在斯德格尔摩系列里，
它是会毕业的，
对，然后会进入到。
其他更大众化，
然后更大规模生产的。
系列里面去，
所以说，
历代设计，
其实本身它是一种很重要的资源，
但是抽象的角度来说，
其实这些设计还是可以连接。
实在记忆和情绪的，
就是如果我们找到适当的时机，
你是可以随时再次去激活这些设计的。
而且它其实也是相当于。
是被验证过的嘛，
只不过就我们现在总是。
互联公司说什么？
比较先验证过怎么样，
其实它的验证，
它的先验其实发生在。
可能是30年前，
是一个更漫长的历史常合中的，
感觉整个啊，
就是把我时尚机啊，
或怎么样，就是都在复古，
就是我感觉，
就是我们先进入了一个复古A值，
你知道吗？
就是让我们常说的时尚，
它是一场轮回嘛，
就它跟我们刚才说的。
一家的无论是在复古啊，
还是它去建立自己的档案，
是一个道理，
就是在设计当中，
复古不是你再度拥有一个单品，
而是说，
你能通过它回到一个。
对当下来说的美好年代，
这其实大家可以观察的看一看，
复古它是不是提供了。
一种对当下的救赎，
比如说，
我们现在会说时尚界，
它比较喜欢千洗年的那种。
经济上行的美，
那它就有可能是，
对，它其实是救赎了。
当下的那种生存压力，
然后像家具呢，
回归到现在主义时期，
就是似乎我们能够通过家具，
暂时再回到当年那个高产能，
审美爆发，
但是信心又不过剩的氛围力。
在这期播客的节目，
我特别想引用作家。
阿兰德伯顿的一句话，
他说我的设计是爱的巨像化，
那一家的复古系的之所以畅销，
是因为它能将这种远处抽象的爱，
昏化成可以购买的形态，
那这个抽象的爱可能是长辈的爱，
它现在变成了奶奶伯也用过的藤衣，
那这个抽象的爱可能是我们的自然的爱，
它最初来源于我们小的时候。
在花园风跑的体验，
那这份爱现在幻化成了。
印花的沙发靠背，
所以不管是老味藤衣，
还是沙发靠背，
他们现在都停留在我们的小窝里，
持续的提醒我们往日那些。
细小而珍贵的美好体验，
对，最后其实我想要提一个小的点，
是我从录的时候一开始就注意到了，
就当做一个小话题，
大家还可以讨论一下，
就是一家的英文，
究竟怎么念？
我一直念Ikea，
但是我们是念Ikea，
然后后来我发现，
它是在英语的文化当中，
比如说美国，
他们会教它Ikea，
然后所以我估计在中国，
如果去念这个牌子的话，
应该还是会念Ikea，
我是记得，
就是一家有那个广告嘛，
一家广告最后，
它会唱一支Ikea，
对啊,
那确实，
那Ikea,
好呀,
那我们这期就到这，
然后我们下期见啦，
好嘞,
下期见，
拜拜,